في الاستوديو ينورنا هذه المره الفنان
المدير ريحنا بعد ما كنا نستقبله عبر
الهوى معانا في الاستوديو في رمضان جبناك
عبر الهوى الصبح
كل عام وانتم بخير كل عام وانت بخير وصحه
وسلامه وان شاء الله شهر محبه وسلام علينا
جميعا باذن الله يا رب
تجمعت مع محمد رمضان على حساباتك التشويق
فيها لمسلسل جعفر العمده حدثنا اكثر عن
هذه الصوره يعني هي الصوره كانت في
الكواليس يعني بقبل تصوير احد المشاهد
على المشهد اللي راح نصوره
ودائما هيك كان محمد فينا صور
يعني قبل اي مشهد نحكي يلا نقول بسم الله
وننزل هاي الصوره
يعني استعداد استعداد دائما ما قبل اي
مشهد لازم يكون في حوار ما بيني وبين بس
ما هو يا منذر يعني
انت نزلت صوره على الانستغرام بس انا انا
عاوزه جمله مفيده عم بتقول انا شوقي فتح
الله مقراش مع حد اكثر من فتحتين والفتحه
الثانيه ماجلها استنوني في مسلسل جعفر
العمده
لانه الفتحه الاولى كان انه يعني الفاتحه
الزواج
والواحد كمان بيقرا الفاتحه على الميتين
فيعني
الفاتحه التانيه كنت ماجلها يعني طيب منذر
هالمسلسل جعفر العمده الجديد منذر يدور في
اطار تشويقي اجتماعي حدثنا اكثر عنوان
فكرته
هو المسلسل كله له علاقه
في صراع الوجود ووجود هذا البني ادم
ومكانته ومكانه وهذا اصعب الصراعات انه
كيف كيف تثبتي في مكانك
بيجي في لحظه مجموعه من الناس بدهم ياخذوا
هذا المكان
فهون بتصير المشكله العميقه ومن له
العاقيه في المكان هذا كمان شيء صعب طيب
منذر اليوم لما احنا بنسمع منذر رياحنا
ومحمد رمضان لما بنحكي عن هذه الثنائيه قد
ايه مهم الانسجام اليوم ما بين نجمين
كبيرين الانسجام الانساني قبل الانسجام
الفني
جدا مهم جدا مهم لانه
بيكون الخوف على الثاني
نفس خوفك على نفسك الخوف ليطلع المشهد في
في في
اناقته يعني انا مثلا في مسلسلات معينه ما
بكونش انا انا ومحمد ولكن بكون همي عليه
وهو عم بينعرض المسلسل او هو اثناء
التصوير يعني هيك وانا مع هاي العلاقه
دائما مع الممثلين تتطور مرحله اللي
بنحكيها الكيمياء او البينج بونج ما بينهم
ليطلع المشهد بشكله اللطيف المشاهدين
ماخذين عنك انطباع منذر انك شخصيه شريره
من مسلسلاتك بدي اطمنهم ابشرها منك في
الواقع شخصيه جديده
طيب انت تجسد في مسلسل جديد شخصيه شوقي
فتح الله شخصيه شريره كمان في رمضان ولا
شيء جديد
بس والله انا شايف عنده وجهه نظر ممرات
وهي صعبه
اصعب الادوار
عدا اصعب الادوار في التمثيل وخط البياني
مش واضح مرات الناس
في الحياه او في الدراما بتتحاسبي على رده
الفعل
يعني على رده فعلك انتم ما لكوش علاقه في
رده فعل انتم علاقه في الفعل في حاله انا
كنت صاحب الفعل فهون احاكم فانت بتتحاكمي
على رده الفعل وينسوا الفاعل اوكي بحكي لك
حتى لو عملوا واحد اثنين ثلاثه ما بصيرش
تعمل واحد اثنين ثلاثه طب هو بالاساس
والله العظيم انه حتى لو عمل هيك
مشكلتي بالحياه وحاسب على رده فعلي لا لا
على اساس الفعل بس بدي اقول لك شغله هل
بتشعر انه انت شكلك بيساعد انه دائما
بتاخد دور الرجل الخطير الرجل المافيا
يعني كانه صار منذر رياحنا محصور بهاي
الادوار الشريره الخطيره شكلك هو
بتحسي ايقونه
من الابواب الصعبه في التمثيل هاي الادوار
ولكن انا عملت يعني ادوار خير محدش شافها
[ضحك]
ما حدش
الشخصيه طيبه ولا شريره لا كل شخصيه لكل
شخصيه لها ابوابها ولكن على فكره مش
الشخصيه الشريره دائما يعني والشخصيه اللي
انظلم فنتيجه هذا الظلم راح على اماكن
ثانيه
اتحاسب عليها بشكل مش لطيف يعني طيب اليوم
احنا بنشوف المسلسل بصيغته الاخيره دائما
كمشاهدين بس اكيد في الكواليس في قصص
وحكايات لا نعرفها ولا ندري عنها واكيد
بتخيل يعني انت ومحمد رمضان شو ممكن يصير
كثير عنده فضول اعرف هل في قصص صارت هيك
تخبرنا عنها حصريا بمساحه
لا في مشاهد يعني
يعني من من باب المرح مثلا في لحظات في
الاكشن اه اللي هو
دول قتلوا بعض بجد
من الكواليس والله العظيم
والله
الا يعني تحصل يعني فريمين يكون فيها ضربه
بشكل فعلي طيب تمثلت الكثير من الادوار
وخصوصي في رمضان ناس تابعت كتير في دراما
رمضان ما هي الادوار او الدور اللي كان
اقرب لمنظر انا دائما بكذب في هذا الشيء
يعني مره بحكي بانه مسلسل الاشتياح من
اقرب الاشياء كل دور له له مكان العزيز
والخاصه يعني
بيحقق لي اللي انا بدي اياه بهذه الدور
ولا بشكل عام بشكل عام لا بشكل عام
الدور اللي بيستفزني اللي هو غير تقليدي
يعني وايمان شاف
[ضحك]
وممكن تفكري فيه بانه انه انه كيف ممكن
اني العب هذا الدور وممكن بحب الادوار
اللي انشافت كثير
ويحكي احنا شفنا اكثر من حد مثل هاي
الشخصيه بس منذر كان في منطقه ثانيه طب
حدثنا عن حارس منذر بالتواجد الرمضاني في
الدراما الرمضانيه انت تحرص على التواجد
ولا شخصيه منذر دراميه هي اللي تخليه يعني
محل اختيار هو رمضان
[موسيقى]
شهر محبه وسلام وتسامح واظن اظنها بعيدا
عن اظن من حقنا من حق الجمهور علينا ان
انا بما ان احنا في في باب الترفيه وفي
باب انه نسعد المشاهدين بلحظه من اللحظات
انسيهم اهمهم لمده ساعه بظن انه واجب
علينا للجمهور اننا نقدمين له عمل رمضاني
ينسى شوي في متاعب الحياه ويدخل في
الشخصيات ويصير حوار المسلسل نفسه طيب
انطلاقا من اللي انا حابه انه انت توجه
كلمه لمشاهدي العربيه ومشاهدين مساء
العربيه عشان يتحمسهم انه يحضروا مسلسل
جعفر العمده لانه في عندك يعني كميه كبيره
خلينا نركز على مسائل العربي يا جماعه
احنا مسائل العربيه يعني
باذن الله يعني اول شيء بدي احكي لكم كل
عام وانتم بخير وجد يعني انا دائما بحكيها
باني انا بحس اني جزء من طاقم العربيه
بشكل بشكل عام
كل عام وانتم بخير
وشوفوا مسلسل العمده لانه يعني
اذا حابب تطلع
لا في في ادوار في ممثلين عاملين شغل جدا
جميل
سيدي المخرج محمد سامي محمد رمضان كل
الكاس الشركه المنتجه اللي قدمت هذا العمل
شوفونا يعني او شوفوا يعني
مسلسل جعفر العمده يعني انا بدي نحكي
للمشاهدين انه اكت
شفنا يخجل امام الكاميرا
بس احنا كتير سعداء بوجودك معنا
واهلا وسهلا فيك في مساء العربيه
كلك ذوق شكرا شكرا يخليك يا رب شكرا